[Music]
okay everybody uh before we jump into
this big interview
i am giving a warning i'm gonna say it
twice if you haven't seen the first
three episodes of season four the
handmaid's tale
do not listen to this and come back
later again
if you haven't seen the first two
episodes the season for the handmaid's
tale leave
uh there's major spoilers here we're
gonna be talking all about what happened
so
just come back later on that note i'm
really excited to have someone really
important today
because this is my first three time
guest
and it's nina kiri aka alma
herself where the first two interviews i
said oh my like an idiot but now i know
it's alma
nina how you doing today i'm good and it
is both ways uh people
people have said it different ways so
it's not you're not an idiot okay thank
you
thank you for making me feel better um i
appreciate it so before we get into
everything that's crazy because
everyone's going to want to hear about
what they just saw what they're like
shocked about
but i want to know how you've been doing
yourself during this crazy time we're
living
and you know how you've been kind of
passing the time i've been kind of in
the same spot as everyone you know just
like
ups and downs kind of trying to just
like come to terms with
what is happening and just a lot
happening all at once
um i think i think it's just been in
waves like i think when
everything first went down just like
okay
gotta deal with this it sucks and um
i started writing more and i think just
just like everybody
writing yoga trying to work out uh
watching movies
just passing the time and kind of for
the first time
having so much free time that that had
no
end date was actually kind of
interesting
just in a study of like how little i
started procrastinating when i didn't
have anything to procrastinate and so i
could actually do certain things that i
i wasn't able to do before
so that was kind of interesting but you
know it starts to get old um it was
it's nice because the film industry has
kind of gone back to normal and i have
been working since september so it's
been
like when i'm on set it just feels
really normal
and it's nice to be around people even
with masks and everything but you know
outside of that
and just life-wise it's it's all right i
think
just problems get more exacerbated
because you're not able to just like
blow off steam and go see friends go see
theater
a movie those types of things kind of
take me back to base
in my life and i think that's just been
that's just been hard just like everyone
else
um but yeah that that's that's kind of
my where i'm at
yeah now now you're stuck doing uh zoom
interviews with bald youtubers like me
sorry no um so dear to me i
i'm so happy no no no i'm just teasing
no but but but it's funny you bring up
because that's what a lot of things
people want to know about is
you talk about you know going back to
work during this crazy time if i'm
remembering correctly
handmaid's tale season four wasn't it
one of the shows that like you guys
started filming and then literally the
pandemic hit like was it a stop start
situation was that like a whole
complicated thing going on yes it was
and um
i think it was it was that that week
when everything happened like uh we just
kept hearing
i'm on another show and that that show
started
to like shut down i was getting all
these emails and and we're like shooting
on the
farm and then every day we're kind of
like waking up getting out of that we
were staying
staying at a hotel nearby because it's
kind of north of toronto right and
every day we'd like get picked up and
kind of look at each other like
is it what are we gonna and then and
then like
no one knew and then on set it was kind
of just like are we gonna shut down i
don't know oh these people just shut
down oh they just shut down later
and then i think it was friday at lunch
uh there was just
a big get-together and everyone you know
like 150 people in a room
right um now seems insane without masks
and every i think we
i think we shut down at lunch that day
um wow
yeah it was kind of weird i i think it
was just like anywhere you know everyone
was kind of scared and weirded out and
didn't really know what was going on so
yeah we had just started filming
two weeks prior um and so it was kind of
just like oh
all this excitement and we're gonna you
know and the location is so was such a
great place to that farm we just had a
lot of like bonding and
anyway we're all excited and about to
start rolling into the season and then
everything
shut down so it was like a stop start
situation
no yeah that just seems crazy but i'm
just happy
it's done now it's here everyone's been
it's like actually added to the hype
because like now we're waiting even
longer and now it's like
okay we're back handmaid's tale and of
course you know
you're in this now epic moment for good
and for bad
in television history when there's a big
killing right and
you know it was hard for me to watch
it's hard for everyone to watch
uh when did you though find out that
alma
was gonna be killed off i found out
uh a couple months before filming
and it was very vague like i didn't
really know very much
um and and yeah i was like i was kind of
like oh my god like oh my god
it actually felt like i was watching the
show and you know you're just like
shocked you can't even believe it but
you know at first i was really
sad but i i ran into lizzie before we
started filming i was doing my fitting
and she was like
she she was telling me she ended up
directing that episode
and she was telling me what she was
thinking for the scene and she was so
excited about it
and it got me really excited and then i
just became like excited about this
whole
like big moment that nova has and then
it just became more
special than uh thinking like oh my god
she's dying
it was like oh my god there's this big
scene and we're gonna do it this way and
we're thinking of
it it kind of became more about making
the scene really cool than like
she's gone right i mean i totally know
what you mean so
i thought the scene and i i think it
came off that way like it was
i know it's sad and it's dark but it was
also epic in its own way where like it
was different the way they did it and it
hit perfectly for what the whole episode
was doing and
i thought you know it's a great way to
go out getting hit by train it's not
even me joking right
so i'm wondering though was it always
going to be that you were hit by a train
or were you like were you campaigning
for that or was it like
was that always going to be alma's
undoing i don't know because
i i think elma as a character has been
really like
just you really i have never known where
she's gonna go on the show i don't think
any of
anybody ever did like even when i i've
told you in the past when i
first even started on handmaids in my
eyes she was only going to be in one
episode
and so like everything that's happened
with her has been such a
someone gets an idea and like gives
gives her the scene and then like oh she
develops this personality so
she's really like morphed so many ways
throughout this whole
journey of hers on the show and so
nothing that has ever happened to alma i
like
expect you know it just kind of happens
with a mixture of like my performance
mixed with writers mixed with ideas so
when everything shut down
we started having zoom meetings of how
to go ppe training for everybody
and we were on a meeting in the summer
last summer before we went back in
september
and uh bruce bruce is so awesome he
really gives everyone such individual
attention and like
care and privately messaged me in the
zoo meeting and i was like oh well
like time to go back to work and die
because he was like honestly like there
is no other way alma could have gone
like she
had to go out with something insane
because right she's
such a like big she's become such a
character
in this show and like such a presence
you know she couldn't just have
something random
happen to her or like something that's
already happened to someone on the show
right yeah i i do think like she had to
go out with a bang
that's the thing like when you're a
character and you're loved on a show
like your character is like
fans if they're gonna have the character
die they want it again to be
something like awesome like it has to be
worthy it can't just be a gunshot you
know like
you got the big one which is awesome and
you know
i wonder now if we're taking let's take
it to nina's perspective on this because
if you're a fan watching this as nina
and we look at this scene and how it
goes down
because i know fans are going to say
this they're going to say that they feel
june got alma killed here because i was
like
let's go you know this train we got to
beat this train
and you know uh jun's just taking her
sweet time to decide what she's gonna do
with lydia
do you feel like that in a sense she
kind of screwed over alma here and
or not you think it's like you're not no
it's situational though because it's
like
you know without june i think that like
what happens in the first three episodes
is like
june kind of starts to be like the ring
leader and
well she always kind of has been but
especially on the farm and with things
that get down and then alma's kind of
like
the command like the deputy whatever
whatever the second in command
right so like they start to really work
together to get things done
and to get [ __ ] done on the farm but
like in that moment i do think it is
kind of situational like
you know you can't really do i think the
strength of this show is that like
we can't do things alone we need each
other to
to do things and like june can't escape
by herself i can't escape without
everybody else
unless we all get away none of us get
away so in that situation it's like
i think it's one of those it's like
we're like an amoeba together and so
trying to get one person to go and then
someone gets shot behind me and then
you know that maybe slow us down so i
don't know it could be i mean listen
june does like
she she [ __ ] things up a lot right
right that's part of her like
imperfect character but i don't know if
it's june's fault per se because for me
i was also kind of thinking like once
the guy starts shooting at us that also
just like slows us down by that
millisecond and maybe that millisecond
could have been that or maybe that
millisecond could have been
june could have taken less time to
decide what to do
right um so i don't know what the answer
is but like the point is is that
situationally just a second and then
we lose her and we and we also lose
brianna
no that that totally makes complete
sense and yeah that's the tough thing
too is like you mentioned we
lose brianna as well and you know we we
lose a lot of june's girls here so
like they're all in their own way just
so significant to june and it makes it
significant to us
as the audience so speaking of the
audience that's listening right now they
don't know that this is
pre-recorded but knowing this is
pre-recorded and we haven't you and me
seen the reaction to this death yet
i'm predicting that you know it's gonna
be crazy because it reminds me a little
bit of like
glenn dying in the walking dead because
it's like a loved character that
a little more mysterious but no one has
an issue with this character of alma so
they're gonna have an issue in a sense
of her dying because they love her so
it's like
i'm wondering are you ready for the
potential reaction here where
you know people are gonna be messaging
you you're gonna get a bunch more
followers they're going to be like no
like it almost puts you in a rock star
area because it's like when a celeb
seriously it's like when a celebrity
passes away early they're almost more
legendary so it's like
i feel like it's made alma now legendary
and i feel like you have to be prepared
for that so like what do you kind of
expecting
i don't i you're right i should get more
prepared and i
i actually i do get sometimes messages
of people being like
if alma dies i swear to god and like
just like random dna
riot yeah so many people and i'm just
kind of like
or like i don't respond or i'm just kind
of like huh wait and see
um so i that already is something i i
guess i should
prepare more for i mean yeah i don't
know i guess i can't really there's only
so much i can do i guess i'll just
see what happens when it happens i'm
very happy people like alma
so it's a nice it's a nice feeling when
people want to fight for her and like
message me about her yeah so let's just
be prepared when there's people with
pitchforks outside bruce miller's house
and uh we won't blame you though okay
in general too so talking about this
because what people don't realize too
about which shows especially with tv
what's awesome about the gig you have is
that
when you get on a big show especially a
big show which is half luck
in that aspect that it became a hit
you're on it is it scary now though
losing such you know a safe gig and a
big gig
in this type of industry or is there
like is it sort of freeing in a way too
like now it's like open door for you
like what how do you feel about that
yeah it's so interesting you say that i
it's funny because
i'm on this show c um and i just started
filming it like
right after i finished handmade and i
think that if i didn't have that and
it's it's the same i have a like a
a role that's just like throughout and
this character is there
and she's in the next season too which
i'll be shooting like
may to october so are you talking about
sea apple tvc yes
oh that's me i love that show okay
that's amazing news continue well
well so like i think that that has been
a buffer for me
first i was i was like oh god like
what's gonna happen
but i think that when i look at it
holistically i
love my time on this show i think that
like handmaid's has given me
so many incredible like personal and
professional experiences in my life
and i actually i think it was kind of a
time you know what i mean i i i like
that
this happened so so far into the show
like i was
like i said to you so many times before
i never expected anything
from this show and everything that
happened happened as a really
nice surprise and i don't think that
always happens like i think a lot of the
times you book a role and you're like
this is going to be big and then you
know maybe it's not as big as you think
or
you get disappointed in some way or it's
less
uh of a a hurdle or less work than you
thought whereas
with with handmaids it's always been
such a like pleasant
treat and surprise everything that
happens because
i i never knew when i would be on it and
how much
and so even getting to be on as much as
i did
i i wasn't as sad like i think i was
kind of like oh god it's the end of an
era but
you know it's kind of time right
eventually eventually it's
like four or five years and you're like
you know i i'm excited for the next
thing to come
and then just like logistically working
and you know being on other shows it was
nice to have
something that i i have again you know
what i mean and i can work
again because i think i think it
wouldn't have made me um
like nervous or like oh god what am i
gonna do if i was if i ended filming
like i finished filming
handmaids in like november and like the
week after i started filming
see and had so it was just nice to have
something i think that if i didn't have
anything and especially because with
corona there's like
not like maybe less going on i'm not
really sure it was nice to have that
sort of buffer but and i think maybe if
i did it i would be kind of more like oh
my god what's happening
right now there's like this void and i
have to fill it um but yeah
either way it's it's been like only
really positive with
handmade so yeah in a way i'm kind of
like this is cool
you know it's to me it's kind of better
than kind of dragging on
and then yeah hell yeah you're doing the
steve carrell
office season seven you're going out on
top and that's the best way to do it
you're learning from the pros yeah so
i'm really grateful for that and i think
that
bruce really tried to um i don't know
just give her
give her a lot more agency and
screen time in the episodes before she
dies and that's just
that was also nice too you know they
were trying to be like let's build her
up too and that was fun to do for me
because i think that like this last
season was the most special season for
me because
colin watkinson uh directed the first
two episodes i think and then lizzy
directed the third one
and it was just like oh my god steve
like it was just so
it was like being surrounded by family
like really yes
people that i just trust and have worked
with and
call and shot my short film like not
last hour of the summer before
and i don't know these are just people
who i've become really close to and so i
felt like
held when i was when we were shooting it
i didn't kind of feel like oh my god i'm
dying no one cares about me
it's really special and everybody is
trying to make it special and that
that just honestly changed my whole
perspective it made me
less upset or like oh god and it just
made me more
feel really grateful to have gone so
long on a show and
and have made such close friends and
people who are who
want to make this special for me not
just kind of like oh you're dying
okay bye oh yeah for sure and it's so
effective too like you said because
clearly like this is um alma gets so
much like screen time in season three
which is awesome and it makes the death
just hurt so much more for the fans
because now we're like glued to her like
seriously so it's like
that worked really well it was super
effective and you know speaking too how
you feel like it's like a family
and all these people that you felt
really close to
is like in general would you say to like
what will you miss the most about the
handmaid's tale just in your life like
what what is that going to be the
hardest part of it to let go
being on set is like for me i always
feel healed when i'm shooting and there
have been so many
ups and downs the past four years that
i've been doing that show
and every time i'm on set i don't know
if it's the chemistry or what's going on
but
i connect so much with especially the
cast like
vahia maddie and lizzy everybody i feel
like
i've had moments of
life personal problems professional
problems and i've always
been able to have conversation and like
soulless on
set you know what i mean sure some i
don't know it's been like a safe haven
you know it's been like the thing that i
can go back to and
always someone's i don't know i can
always talk to someone
i don't know yeah it's just like going
back to it it's a nice
vibe it's like in high school when you
have like your crew and you can just
say whatever too that's why i feel on
hand
not even just cast crew and just like
people who you you've been with for
a long time you know like time goes by
and all of a sudden you're like wow i've
actually known you for a really long
time and
i really love and respect you in so many
ways and that's so
rare especially you you realize that
once you start working once i work on
other things i'm like
i want to go back to handmade yeah no
100
um i heard a rumor too is it true that
you kept one of the pigs from the farm
or you you didn't do that
that's a rumor okay i did not okay just
wanted to put it to rest
but i will say mckenna who is in the
third season
she was she's like an animal whisperer
and she
like flourished on the farm and
she's like honestly has a sixth sense
for animals that she'd just be saying
there's like i feel like there's a snake
over there and then she'll walk over
pick up a snake she'd pick up frogs so
uh
if anyone stole an animal it would have
been her oh that's amazing
um so nina my last question for you
before i let you go is if you could go
back in time and talk to
young nina who's just getting a gig on
this show
what which advice would you give her
like any lessons you kind of learned
i would say trust yourself trust your
ability
because i think that so often as an
actor but i
honestly think anyone you question
who you are and what you can give and
you don't realize
how powerful exactly and only you
are and how much how much really you can
give and how much power you have to
move people and to to change things just
with your
presence and energy because i think i in
the beginning you know i was kind of
like shy and whatever
didn't want to you know i i was just
kind of like
oh i'm just here and i'm not going to
try and like cause a stir
whatever and just by doing the work and
trying to
play off of the scenes and the other
characters and the other actors i
i feel like it was just interesting to
watch myself create something when i
didn't know if i was
capable of doing that that's great just
advice
and i think that's you know something
now as you're becoming more and more
of a vet in this industry will help
younger actors and actresses and um
yeah i mean look the fans are gonna miss
you you're cast your crew's gonna miss
you but
it's exciting all the things you're
talking about that are coming up that
you're gonna be in i i'm sure they're
all gonna come with you to watch those
things
and i wanted to thank you personally
because again as i said before this is
you're the first three-time guest you
were also the first two-time guest at
the time
and you're one of my first guests ever
you did that first interview with me
when i was literally
nobody and you gave me a shot and that's
why this stings even more for me and
it goes even deeper because like when i
see you get killed off in the show it's
like
spiritual for me in a weird way too and
i think fans seriously and i think fans
will feel that way too like
it's more than just a character they're
losing you know there is a connection we
have
watching actors and actresses and maybe
we're not with them all the time but we
feel
something there's something out there i
feel and for you it's
it's just that like you're just an
awesome person to me because again you
gave me that shot i don't think you know
how much that helped me and just what i
do so
i want to thank you for that and um
yeah and before i lied about last
question before i let you go one more
thing
um yeah that's so nice of you to say
honestly and i
like i feel the same way about you i
there's
i i don't know why i was like i feel
like when you first called me for that
interview or messaged me i was like yeah
this guy seems cool so i really
appreciate you too and like
your love and support honestly same
ditto right back at you
thank you i really appreciate that and
um no and
i i mean look everyone just if you like
what nina does she also directs she
writes
she does everything she has shorts she's
made it's really exciting time for her
and you can check out her old
filmography and yeah i mean it's
exciting i can't wait to see you in the
show c
and everything's going to come up and
but thank you i'm speaking for the fans
here thank you for being such an awesome
actress and character
on the handmaid's tale and your bonnet
will always live on
thank you thank you i wish i had taken a
bonnet or something
um on the last day i was like god i
gotta i'm sure if i call them and ask
maybe they'll give me something but you
need you need a token something you need
a token
that's something well you're gonna get
that token i i believe in you
thanks so much for joining me nina and
i'll definitely be talking to you on
your future projects
thank you